the great Douglas Murray I don't know
that we've played a clip of Douglas
Murray lately Douglas Murray who's my
friend Great British conservative
thinker actually lives in New York right
now I'm working on getting him to
Florida one thing at a time he was on
the Piers Morgan show debating one of
these uh far left woke LGBT activists
and you tell me does anyone do it better
than my good friend Douglas Murray I
don't get this Sam Smith thing it just
seems like every week he deliberately
babe I'm sorry they even though there's
only one of them
why why is Sam Smith there no please do
address Douglas first but I just need
why is that's how they identify that why
is it why is one person they because
that's how they identity why have I got
to go along with it because they've
asked you to to me he's just on an Ever
deteriorating campaign to be as vulgar
and defensive as he possibly can am I
missing something
uh he's doing what pop stars have done
for decades which is trying to shock as
a means to get publicity and of course
it's pretty successful I mean we're
talking about him at the moment uh but
it's it's striking that it's sort of
very unoriginal I mean all the stuff
he's doing the sort of over sexualized
stuff the sort of satanic stuff Madonna
did this 40 years ago
um uh you know pop stars have done this
and more for decades now uh I think the
only thing that Sam Smith has got sort
of going of him on this and the thing
actually is making people notice him on
this is that first of all he keeps sort
of throwing these bollards in the way of
everyone by changing his alleged gender
all the time yeah okay he came out some
years ago
he came he came out as many years ago as
gay and then he said he was actually uh
gender queer and then he said he was
non-binary and he said he didn't know
what it meant of course he didn't
because there's no such thing they but
he's he said that they were going to uh
he said that he thought he was gender
Quinn he didn't know what it meant but
he said that he would explain it someday
when he did know and I thought so I
think if you're going to make everyone
else distort the language you should
know what you're talking about first so
he does that to get publicity obviously
and the other thing he does is he does
this sort of
um you know like taking all his clothes
off stuff and and the thing that makes
it different from other people is that
when oh I don't know Justin Timberlake
or Rihanna or someone stripped down they
do so because they look good like their
bodies look good Sam Smith is like pudgy
and very ugly and so people look at it
and he looks ridiculous and the problem
is is that he's saying don't ridicule me
but it's hard not to ridicule people
when they present this is disgusting
what are you talking about we're allowed
to find him no you are not it's like
keep commenting on what people look like
all the time if they're gonna dress like
that on a stage in front of millions of
people around the world absolutely I can
thank you for getting the pronoun
correct I really appreciate that do you
think what we're looking at right now is
sexy yeah I do you're both CIS white
straight man you can carry on I'm not
assist anything first of all I am white
secondly I am a man thirdly I've been
out and gay my entire adult life I was
out as gay when you were still prancing
around talking about whether or not you
were if I were you I would do the
tiniest bit of research before opening
your mouth you're embarrassing yourself
that's probably why people would I don't
think so all right embarrassing yourself
shame to the queen you know what I tell
you who's really embarrassing them
stupid sod
I gotta call Douglas after this like I I
just love him this kid see what this kid
thinks is that your sexuality is an
ideology right so he hears Douglas
Murray pushing back against Sam Smith or
pushing back against the broader
lgbtqi plus Elemento P two-spira thing
and he automatically thinks you must be
straight because he's assuming it's not
a sexuality it's a political ideology
and thus
is the problem